every book it in the world in America is
legal to read everything you can say in
the world other than causing harm to
another human being is legal to say in
this country it has to be under the
First Amendment you cannot like it you
can be offended by it but those two
things have to be true those are no
longer true here
I just saw something this morning I was
reading them and this blew me away
apparently Amazon uh the largest seller
of books in the world
has banned an enormous stable of books
based on uh order from the Department of
Justice
that should scare the [ __ ] out of people
and you know all the things happening to
these people in in uh at the FBI showing
up or investigating uh someone from the
news media that is writing a story about
Biden and all the things
there's it's so distant from people that
are reading it they can't translate or
or come to the conclusion what if that's
me
yeah and and it started out because
apparently there's an author in Russia
who is one of the one of the Alexander
Dugan yes the philosophy yes yeah and
and his books are prominent to in every
educated person's bookshelf because
apparently he's written I've never read
anything he's written but this gentleman
went to look for them and Tucker Carlson
had mentioned that he went to look for
them and they're there's not one on the
site none of them on the site so then
what the left does is well it's a you
know when they when they have this that
I love this argument oh it's a private
company they don't have well it yeah
there's no First Amendment issues until
the government is involved in the
decision-making process which is we need
you to ban these books we want you to
ban these books well again
a book can't offend you unless you read
it
so you know and then the the the the the
throwback is well the the conservatives
in the South are trying to ban books
well it's my understanding that the
books they're trying to not ban but
remove from elementary schools are
basically adult
pornography or whatever that might be
and I could be wrong but
this is the I mean we're have again
but we're having discussions that five
years ago we would have just said no
that'll never happen
and not now we're living it yeah my name
is Scary My thing is you know in in how
many times is it like a kid is grow
grows up in a Family household that
parents get a divorce
one side of the family tells you stories
about the other side of the parent well
yeah let me tell you who your mom was
let me tell you your dad was and the kid
could believe it for five years
sometimes ten years sometimes 20 years
and then 20 years later like why'd you
say that about Mom why'd you say that
about that that wasn't true you made me
not like Dad for four years right
because that's what's happening and the
kid is in the middle experience mom and
dad getting a divorce and the kid is the
one that loses 10 20 years of his life
right so to me I think America is my
opinion I have four kids that's where my
opinion let me tell you I feel that pain
I mean I'm I I I was willing to put and
still willing to put five billion
dollars on the line if Trump and Obama
are willing to do a three-hour podcast
together to figure out a way to get
people to come together and talk on what
they actually agree on because one is
the voice for Mega the other one is the
voice for the the left what can we do to
bring them together right because more
people are going to sit there and say
this kind of does make sense America's
especially before systemic racism yeah
right President Obama believes inherent
systemic racism in this country which we
know there's racism in this kind there's
always going to be racism in this
country because we're a free country and
you're allowed to be racist we've
marginalized those people the clan no
longer has a voice at any table that
matters to anyone they still exist but
if you had left had their way they would
Define hate and they would get be able
to jail people that they deemed were
hate speech
that's a perfect example is that that
gets back to Maga is seen as this Ultra
racist movement and President Obama
believes this country is systemically
racist
those two things don't have a meat in
the middle
right I mean we can listen I am as
conservative Finance fiscally
conservative as anybody on the planet
like look socially I don't care I don't
care my middle son started the lgbtq
club in high school I had kids that were
transitioning coming in and out of my
house my whole my son's eyes really
never ever mattered to me I didn't care
we opened our home to everybody I don't
care about stuff like that has nothing
to do with what kind of person you are
how you treat me or how I treat you
but if you listen to but if you're going
if you Google me I'm a I'm an
islamophobe I'm a homophobe I'm a trans
all the things that's that's an
intentional people intentionally are out
there ruining other people so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]